-Welcome back, buddy.
It's always good to see you.
We have a lot to talk about.
-We have a lot to talk about.
-We really do.
-First of all, the beard.
You're looking handsome,
can I just say?
-Aw, no, stop.
-No, I mean it. It's nice.
It's like, I can't grow a beard,
so whenever I see somebody
do it, I'm just --
I, like, cheer from the rafters.
"You go, Jimmy!"
-Yes, this took me
six months to do it.
-I can't even do it.
-Oh, come on, you're a stud.
-How have you been? I haven't
seen you in a while, man.
-I haven't seen you, buddy.
Yeah, I'm happy you're here.
-Yes, yes.
-Thanks for being here.
You kind of shocked the world.
You shocked me, at least,
a couple weeks ago.
You announced that you're
leaving "The Daily Show."
-Right, yes.
-And that your last show
is December 8th.
-That is indeed correct.
-Why?
-Um. Why not?
[ Laughter ]
No, you know what --
you know what I think?
It's funny how people ask it.
Like, people ask you
this question as if
you're telling them bad news.
-Yeah.
-You know, and I can understand
that, but I think --
I think everybody
has gone through a period
of looking at their lives.
You know, every single person.
We were -- we're in our
apartments for two years.
You know, the world changed.
We experienced collective grief.
I think if you don't
look at your life
and think about what you'd
like to do differently,
then you haven't experienced
what we've all experienced,
you know?
And so I think of this
as a joyous thing, you know?
I lived through a crazy time.
I shared it with people who were
kind enough to share it with me.
We went through something,
and what's on the other side?
I don't take anything
for granted anymore.
I don't believe
that life is a given.
I don't assume that things
will come to me.
And so, you know,
I just go, like,
"This is it. This is time."
And leave -- when people say
"Why are you leaving?"
'Cause imagine if it was
the other way around.
I go, like, "I'm leaving,"
and then people are like,
"Yeah, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-"It's about time."
-Yeah, like, leave --
leave when --
-Leave when people go, "Why?"
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I like that.
Leave when it's still good.
Leave when you're still loved.
Leave when you still have
the energy to enjoy it.
I still have three months
to have a ton of fun
with everybody at the show.
-Yeah.
-And I'm gonna do that.
-Do you have plans on what
you're going to do next, or...?
-Everything. Everything.
-Everything?
-Everything.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna get drumming lessons
from Quest.
-Yeah, Quest.
-You know this.
We're getting our
drumming lessons going.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, he'll join you.
-No, you know what?
I'm so excited to do everything.
I didn't get to travel as much,
doing stand-up around the world.
I'm excited to do that
-Yeah.
-I used to go to a country and I
would be there for weeks on end.
I would learn
parts of the language.
I would learn about the culture.
I would do a show based
around that.
I'm gonna get back to
doing that.
Producing, you know?
Just working behind the camera.
-Yeah.
-Working on different ideas,
you know?
Going back home,
spending more time with family
in South Africa.
Everything is what
I'm gonna be doing.
-Stand-up is --
-The show is hard, Jimmy.
We're here every day, Jimmy.
-You don't need to tell me.
-Do I need to tell you this,
Jimmy?
-No, you don't have to tell me.
-Why aren't you leaving, Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
It's hard.
-I have an announcement tonight.
-No, don't do it!
[ Drumroll ]
No, they'll blame me.
Don't -- You stop
playing those drums, now!
[ Laughter ]
-I do want to see you
do stand-up,
because man, oh, man,
you're selling out these shows,
and I follow you on the socials
and I see what you're doing
and I go --
You just sold out in Toronto.
-It was amazing.
It was truly, truly amazing.
-Two nights in a row, right?
-Yeah, two nights
at the Scotiabank Arena,
and I don't take it for granted.
-You're doing arenas!
-I remember when I was
in Toronto,
doing a 200-seat venue.
-Yeah.
-People would come, I don't even
know how they knew me.
Literally, you go to
someplace in the world
and people go,
"I'm your biggest fan!"
This was before social media
was really a thing.
I was like, "How do you know me?
I'm a little creeped out,
but I appreciate this."
-Yeah, of course.
-Because how do you know me?
And to go from that to now
playing these giant rooms,
I don't take it for granted.
I'm going back to
the small rooms again,
because that's where you
start the set.
But it's been
a wonderful progression,
to see where you start,
where you get to,
and going back to that
and appreciating it.
It was fun.
-I remember being nervous
not being able to
sell out a 200-seat comedy club.
-I'm still nervous.
-They make you do radio
in the morning, too.
-I am still nervous.
-Oh, please.
-Radio's fun, though.
-Oh, yeah.
-But not when it's like,
5:30 in the morning
and you've got to be funny.
I'm like, Oh, my God.
-And they've got so much energy,
and they've all got
the radio voices.
They're like,
"Wake up to the morning!"
[ Overlapping shouting ]
[ Imitating sound effects ]
[ Applause ]
-Call in!
Call in!
-I didn't even have my coffee!
[ Laughter ]
-You know, the "Black Panther"
sequel is coming out soon.
-Yes.
-And I don't know if
a lot of people know this,
but you were in the original
"Black Panther."
-I don't know if I believe this.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
These are rumors
that I've been told.
-No, no, this is a real thing.
-i don't know,
I think people just assume,
because it's like, Wakanda,
it's from Africa,
I'm from Africa.
-No, no.
-And people are just like,
"You were there."
I'm like, "No, I was in Africa."
It's similar,
but it's not the same.
-It's not Wakanda, yeah.
But you are
the voice of the A.I.
-I'm the voice of Griot, yeah.
-Yeah, the --
-I'm basically, it's like
African Siri, that's what I am.
[ Laughter ]
That's essentially
what I'm doing.
-You've made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you just tell every
single human that you knew
on this planet that you were
in "Black Panther"?
And you're like, "Dude,
I'm in the biggest movie ever."
-No. No, you know why?
Because I hate spoilers.
-Yeah.
-And so I wouldn't spoil it
even for my friends,
to let them know that
I'm doing a --
I genuinely don't --
I don't watch trailers,
for instance.
-You don't?
-No, I hate trailers.
-Because you don't want to know?
-No, like, I like getting
into the movie
and not knowing what's coming,
what's gonna happen,
not anticipating a scene,
not thinking about --
Sometimes they'll put a thing --
Have you noticed they'll
put a thing in the trailer
that's not in the movie?
And sometimes you wait
for the whole movie --
You're like,
"Where's the thing?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"No, on the trailer,
you did the thing."
-"Yeah, but the trailer --
the trailer had --"
-"Where he's holding up
the baby's."
-"There's a moment."
-"He's wearing the baby's
coat and he's --"
-Then there's no --
there's no baby's coat.
So, uh, no, I --
-That'd be a good scene.
-I enjoy the experience of
going to the movies,
sitting there with my popcorn,
and not knowing
what's gonna happen,
and then just enjoying it.
Go, you know --
-I'm gonna do that.
I wanna do that with you.
-Go along for the ride.
What's the worst
that can happen?
-Let's just go
see a random movie that we --
neither one of us knows
exactly what's gonna happen.
-I do that all the time.
You should come with me.
-Really? I will come with you.
I cannot wait.
-It's a lot of fun.
-I know you probably
won't tell me now,
but are you in
the new "Black Panther?"
[ Laughter ]
Of course you're not
gonna tell me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why would you tell me?
You just explained to me that
you don't like spoilers.
-I'm just saying
you should watch it.
-I am gonna watch it.
I'm gonna, yeah.
I'll watch it?
Do you want me to watch it
or listen to it?
-You should -- Both.
-Okay.
-It'd be weird
if you only watch.
If you just come into
movies with your headphones.
-If I'm going for your voice,
I dunno.
I wanted to ask you, because
this made me really laugh.
Halloween is coming up.
I don't know if you get into it
or don't get into it.
-I love Halloween.
It took me a while to get
into it, because --
for those who are from Africa,
you know what I'm talking about,
Halloween is not something
we really celebrate there.
Because my parents, my mom,
my grandma, everyone,
they just go,
"that's witchcraft."
-Ah. Well, yeah.
-So if I was like, "Ah, I'm
gonna dress up as the devil,"
my mom was like,
"Then I will send you to hell."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there was no --
-It's not Trick-or-Treat.
-So it's something that
I got into in America.
-It's a little different.
-And I'm in now.
I'm in. I'm enjoying it.
-Yeah.
This is my favorite thing,
one of my favorite things
you've ever done.
Last year you dressed as --
you went as The Weeknd.
-I did, indeed.
-Yeah.
And it was so convincing.
-I did, indeed. That's me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's me.
-I know it's you.
-Yeah.
-But it was so convincing you
told me that people thought
that you actually were
The Weeknd.
-Can I tell you?
This is one of the strangest
experiences I've ever had.
'Cause I know The Weeknd
and I look similar
from certain angles.
The joke I have with him, is I
go, "I'm The Weekday," right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And so --
I decided for Halloween,
I was like, "Ah, what's easy?"
I was like, "This is great. I'm
just gonna go as him," right?
-Of course.
-And I'm walking downtown
in New York. It's Halloween.
Everyone is dressed up
as other things.
Someone screams, "The Weeknd!"
[ Laughter ]
So I go, "Yeah, that's
the outfit. I get it."
Then she's like, "Can I get
a selfie, The Weeknd?"
And I was like, "Wait,
you think I am The Weeknd?"
She's like, "You're The Weeknd."
What are you doing here?"
Then I say,
"I'm not The Weeknd."
She's like, "You're lying.
I recognize you."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Wait. Why --
So why would The Weeknd be
The Weeknd for Halloween?"
[ Laughter ]
How does this work?
-He wouldn't dress...
-"What is happening right now?"
And then she got angry.
She got angry.
I was like, "I'm not."
She's like, "Don't lie. Stop
lying. Just take a photo.
I love your, 'I can't feel my
face when I'm with you.'"
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "I'm not The Weeknd."
She was like,
"Why are you being like this?"
I said,
"'Cause I'm not The Weeknd."
-Yes, of course.
-She's like,
"I thought you were nice."
Then I'm like, "Well,
guess The Weeknd's not nice.
I don't know what's
happening right now."
-Now you're giving him
a bad name?
-Yeah. So now I'm gonna
go as him every year.
[ Laughter ]
-He should go as himself
and have one night off.
Let's talk about your
new project here,
"The Turning Point."
-Yes. I'm very excited.
-This is very, very interesting.
It's a bunch of documentaries.
It's on MSNBC.
-Yes. Yes.
-And these films look at issues
like climate change,
voting rights.
-Right.
-And how do you choose what
stories to cover with these?
-Well, I'm really lucky that we
had a fantastic team
that came together to
create this idea
for looking at the news beyond
just the moment that it happens.
You know, I know America
loves the take of the day.
I get that.
You know, I do a daily show.
But I sometimes think
that we lose perspective
if we don't think about
the whys and the hows,
the story behind the story.
How does it affect people in
a way that you didn't consider?
How do you even
separate yourself
from the surface issue
to speak about
what's actually happening?
So, for instance, you know,
talking about polarization.
Everyone says,
"Oh, America's polarized.
Everybody thinks this.
Everybody thinks that."
But, you know, for one of
the documentaries,
we look at, do you ever
consider what it's like
to live in a country
where people are consuming
two completely different
versions of what's on the news?
You know, everyone goes,
"This is my reality,"
and another person says,
"Well, this is my reality."
What does that do to a country?
And that's what we look at
in one of those.
You know, I've been lucky enough
that the documentaries
are produced and directed by
some of the most amazing people.
For instance, Leonardo DiCaprio
produces one of
the documentaries
that looks at climate change
and how it ties
people's lives together.
For instance,
the wildfires in Portugal,
how people's lives
were destroyed,
how they found each other.
But then also how it ties
into a larger narrative
of how people
move around the Earth
and why they move
around the Earth.
-And how did we get there,
and also what are we learning,
and how and what
are we changing?
-Yeah. But just, without --
a lot of the time it's,
everything is associated
with blame.
And I think sometimes if we have
a conversation about what is,
without looking at who you
want to or not want to blame,
you can just have
a discussion around the why,
and then you can go from there.
I feel like we live
in a world where
people argue about everything,
and I don't think
you have to agree with
everyone on everything.
You can go,
"That's my parking spot."
I go, "That is my parking spot."
But now we're getting to
a world where I go,
"That's my parking spot,"
and somebody goes,
"What parking spot?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, that's scary.
-That's scary, yeah.
-Let's disagree...
-There is a parking spot.
-...on the parking spot.
-That's what we can agree on.
-Yeah, but let's agree that
there is one in the first place.
And that's all I'm
trying to do here,
is trying to tie
people worlds together
to help them understand that
they may not agree on issues,
but just give them a different
lens to see it through.
And so that's been really joyous
in just working through
new stories
with a longer lead,
with a bit more patience,
with a bit more time to build
a little more context.
-The first one is called
"Shouting Down Midnight."
-Yes.
-What is that?
-It's a really,
really wonderful look
at how one lawmaker --
one person, in fact,
can go on to create,
you know, ripples in a pond.
You have Wendy Davis, who
stood up and filibustered a law
that has affected
so many millions of women
around this country.
And she did it in her state,
in her world.
And then what we try to show you
is how these ripples go on
to create change
all over the country.
And it becomes less about
that incident,
and more about how people
can create more change
than they think they can
in the moment
that they dip themselves
into a pond.
-Yeah. I love that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a look at the first film
of the series,
"Shouting Down Midnight."
-We are coming back.
We are coming back.
[ Cheering ]
-There were these moments
in the day
when the building would
literally come alive.
I could feel it under my feet.
-Let her speak. Let her speak.
Let her speak. Let her speak.
-Upset by the
the crowd's behavior,
Lieutenant Governor Dewhurst
referred to the folks
who were there as an unruly mob.
They've since taken that mantra
and worn it with pride.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The documentary series
"The Turning Point" premieres
October 23rd
at 10:00 P.M. on MSNBC.
Trevor, thank you so much
for being here,
and we'll support
anything you ever do.
-Always. Thank you.
-You know, you're a good man.
-Thank you very much.
-Congratulations.
The Weeknd, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]